I don't know I'm having stomach problems
so you're not even pregnant man what
you're not even pregnant man at yeah
yeah I guess I'm not the one having
stomach problems I just came from
literally the doctor oh let's talk about
it wait wait no is this the start of the
episode could be are we starting
now
good good morning good
morning just hopefully that caused one
or two car crashes or hopefully it
didn't I mean I wouldn't ever hope for
you to crash your car no but people have
ever I didn't notice that yeah who put
that there I noticed it I didn't say
anything
oh it's one of those adorable little
picture right there I responded in my
head oh hit you with the ultrasound
pictures oopsie now that's a
flex hard copy yeah I just keep
mommy you keep the ultrasound on you you
just keep that thing on me just in case
just in case someone's like I don't
believe that your wife's actually
pregnant yes she is you could have
printed those out though what do you
mean those could have been just from
your home printer you to search
ultrasound and big old ruse yeah no they
uh a gun they print those out every
single time what there's a gun bar in
there somewhere I keep the ultrasound on
me ah nice something you know yeah yeah
anyway you got stomach problems no I
just Obie said you guys okay are you
guys good and I was like well not really
not
100% okay I did I just like ate an
entire breakfast burrito on the way here
so you you said you came from the doctor
and I stopped to get a burrito on the
way okay then what happened the doctor
say said the baby's all
good oh [__] no when you said when you
said I'm having stomach problems that's
it's not was not from the doctor the
doctor was unrelated to that confused
yeah yeah the the stomach problems are
from the burrito yeah the doctor was for
my wife's stomach problems or not
problems stomach you know we got this
issue on the
way this thing stomach blessings I
should say yeah my wife's stomach
blessing I think that's how they
described it before like Latin was real
ironed out yeah the blessing is in the
stomach
gut blessing yeah so every that's that's
all good and every time you go they
print out a like they do an ultrasound
every single time nice and they just
print pictures but by the end they're
just like you've seen the baby aund
times so they're kind of like there's
the and they print it off and you're
like like I don't know what any of these
are I think that's a kid like what is
that that's just nothing oh yeah I think
they just do it because it's like habit
H you know yeah they're like okay
there's the umbilical cord and they
print it out and they like moved by then
so then it's just a black screen you're
like
okay
thanks yeah yeah so what is that an
alien yeah
yeah is that real how did you get no
that's did I give that to
you so love island is coming back with
love Island Allstars o which I thought
was the same as love Island games but
it's a different
show but with yeah do you know who's
who's on it yet have they said [__] man
if they brought back like there's so
many [__] good people yeah you
know all the EX Islanders rumored wait
oh is this the
rumor yeah Obie would be sick yeah yeah
Obie you're gonna be on
it bye bye not even knowing holy [__]
they cast
me Paige Thor I don't remember her I
remember Paige she was the fan favorite
wasn't it Paige and Jack yeah jocks
jocks okay keep going down I'd recognize
her if I saw her oh MOA of course she
was on the love Island games too as a
host keep going Fay would be
good
yeah yeah man all your all your
favorites Megan wow but she just [__]
left love Allen games is so funny one of
the episodes they're like yeah Megan's
got a medical problem and then she just
wasn't in the rest of the show medical
problem
I wonder what her medical problem was
Georgia Georgia she was on love is games
too she kind
of she kind of what you said what oh I'm
not like I'm just saying she kind of
sucks like as a person she just was kind
of like you said her face or something
and you were like like she's kind of
looking horrible these days no no no if
they if they want love Island Allstar
they got to go get the original winners
from season one to I want to see that
guy from season 1 who's like a
construction worker who just chain smoke
outside the Villa yeah I didn't watch
season one and he didn't work out he's
like the epitome of just a regular dude
yeah I want to see that guy in there and
just he just cleans up yeah they need to
take it back to those days like when it
was about smoking cigarettes yeah and
hooking up yeah everyone in the Villa
used to smoke cigarettes remember that
yeah look up Johnny season 1 and
Chris Chris Chris top right bring back
Chris I don't
remember Chris and chem you don't
remember that season three oh my God
vaguely yeah dude they got to go back to
smoking onet all of them used to smoke
and smoking cigarettes we all know is
good and cool yeah that guy on the right
oh yeah okay dude that that's bivo
that's [__]
bivo
yeah maybe that's what's next for bivo
love Island love Island oh my goodness
that would be so good oh my goodness God
damn that'd be so good so for this
challengeing speech you have like uh y
big up F yeah banging she's banging and
uh my girlfriend at home's going to be
so pissed but I'm here I'm here to lock
in with
Fay
bro uh the the the game they have to
like swallow [__] and spit it into each
other's mouths yeah oh he would bivo
would love that bivo is like open up
yeah one fell just swallowing it all
like dude bivo you got to save some spit
it into the [__] thing that's what
the games about he's like it's well
seasoned is it that's not what they
brought me Sor it's well seasoned is it
is it what's this guy up to man I want
to
know where are they now where are they
now yeah dude John CLK Clark bring back
John
Clark this guy was [__] weak too
that's the love island effect right
there 400,000 followers and he gets 12
comments not that I'm engagement
watching damn bro you know I feel like
that's like a you know pocket watching
yeah in a way yeah it is but that is
kind of crazy isn't it it is but I mean
bro that was 2015 when's the last time
he even posted June yeah it's been a
minute thinking about how I am about to
smash the Palm Beach Casino he's
thinking about it you know what I love
too I mean he probably won he still post
that's thing about
gambling yeah for some reason I've got a
gambling
kick I got a little kick for gambling he
still posts like it's 2005 or some [__]
yeah sepia Phil and all yeah look at me
eating this is me in a pool 89 69
weeks seems like he's doing
well good on him
man